[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Georgia
Campbell Ramsay personality host of The
George Campbell YouTube channel and
co-host of the smart money happy hour
with Rachel Cruz is my co-host today
we're answering your questions about
your life and your money and we invite
them right now the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Tom's going to start off this hour
in Atlanta Georgia hi Tom welcome to the
Ramsey Show hey Dave how are you better
than I deserve sir what's up in your
world
well I have I have a question for you
and I hope all is good in your
way and finally have enough money to pay
off mortgages if I wanted to and I
wanted to know should I do that or
should I keep them financed
okay
I have a home under construction it's a
construction loan at three and a half
percent which is going to change if I
close with them under uh 15 or 30 year
mortgage
to approximately five and a half percent
and I I have the funds to pay it off and
I just needed to know should I pay it
off so what is that pile of money that
you got
um it's a nice chunk of change and it to
pay off the house I don't think it would
affect my lifestyle how much did you get
Tom I'm not allowed to pay those exact
numbers why who who Who's Who your mom
ever told you you couldn't no no no I'm
under confidentiality agreement oh uncle
was it seven figures what are we talking
here north of a million
yeah yeah okay well hey the reason I was
asking was congratulations well thank
you very incredible well done touchdown
Tom well done hey it was a touchdown
very happy 20 years fun how old are you
53 good for you and how much is the
mortgage balance gonna be
um it'll be with in June when the house
is finished it'll be around a million
and the home will be worth about 2
million because I've already put in a
chunk okay so the the chunk of change
under confidentiality is well north of 5
million then
yeah it's a good number yeah okay all
right so so you can pay this off and
still have a big old pile of freaking
money that's that's what I want to make
sure before I move forward in this so
here's the thing
a good way sometimes for me uh and I use
it a lot personally to decide if I want
to keep something or if I want to invest
in something is I reverse engineer it
okay let's just pretend your pile of
money was five million dollars and you
had a million dollar mortgage okay and
so if you pay off the mortgage yeah
you've got a pile of four million
dollars and you have a paid for two
million dollar house okay is that right
I got my numbers right didn't I well
yeah assuming assuming my assumption
about the confidentiality close Okay so
anyway that's our pretend scenario and
now if the house if there let's reverse
engineer it let's pretend that you had a
two million dollar paid for house and
you had four million dollars in
Investments would you go borrow a
million on your paid for house so that
you had five million in Investments
no same difference
fair enough and that tells me what to
see see what I mean by reverse
engineering it so you can even do that
with a boat that's sitting in the
driveway okay the boat's worth ten
thousand dollars if I sold the boat I'd
have ten thousand dollars let's pretend
I got ten thousand dollars in the pile
in the middle of the table would I go
buy a boat yeah I love boats okay then
don't sell your boat but no of course I
wouldn't buy another boat I hate the
stupid boat well then it's time to sell
the boat well it's taking up space in
the driveway so you just reverse
engineer it and that's a sunk cost
analysis yeah this is a a good situation
to have but a lot of people Dave what
they see on paper is well Dave if I
invested that money I can make more than
the mortgage interest wouldn't that be
the smart thing to do and the
interesting thing is when we did that
larger study a millionaires ever done in
North America 10 167 of them the number
of them that borrowed on their house to
invest and as a result built wealth was
precisely zero we couldn't find one
not even one that said I became a
millionaire because I maximized The
Leverage on my personal residence and
put that money in mutual funds not one
well the millionaire guy on on Tick Tock
told me differently Dave well that's
all those people tell the truth well he
had an online course that was going to
show me how to do it I know
oh that's how he made his money not
through leveraging debt that makes sense
yeah he's yeah you know if I
that's why we put stuff on Tick Tock I
mean I was going to avoid Tic Tac it
drives that whole thing brought me nuts
and we just started flooding it with
Ramsay stuff to try to flush out
yeah just flush out some of the sewage
if you just take up the space with clean
water the sewage has to go somewhere
else you know it's just oh my gosh so we
thought okay we can either ignore this
sewage mess or we can just put a bunch
of cleanliness in there and oh these
people but yeah I mean yeah you you
watch some of these guys honestly most
of you have good walking around since if
you'll take a second and just watch the
body language of a couple of these
characters
you can 100 see they're lying
that their scenario is com I have 25
million dollars in mortgages and he's
got a baby on his hip oh you've seen
that one yeah that one went viral that
one's just so that guy's so lying that
is not true you just watch it watch his
watch his eyes watch his mouth I mean
the guys just you don't have to be a FBI
trained to figure out this guy's not
telling the truth okay so it's just a
straight up lie so uh honestly people
the data that we did in this uh
millionaire study is airtight I mean we
used all of the research techniques we
used an outside research firm to make
sure we weren't doing confirmation bias
we weren't falling for some of the other
research methodology problems you can
get into because we actually know a
little bit about research and statistics
here at Ramsey and so we this this data
is so freaking solid that if you don't
agree with the conclusions you're what's
known as wrong
so I mean you just got to keep that in
mind it's just straight up the truth now
uh so you know the number of whole lot
the number of millionaires that made
became millionaires because they bought
whole life life insurance precisely zero
not one
the number of them that leased their
cars because this is what wealthy people
do not now some of them did at least
their cars but none of them told us that
it was anything but a mistake yeah okay
what was the dumbest thing you ever did
with money they would say I leased a car
about a whole life policy these these
are the things that kept me from
Building Wealth it's well it's so much
simpler and more boring than you ever
thought it's it is just put money in
your 401k oh that's all the funds pay
off your house it's a problem with this
stuff it's too boring Dave it's just
really we need a sexier approach make it
real complicated do a lot of math on a
board real quick I need a white board
and I need to be to dance around and I
need to do a double back flip and get a
Family Partnership Double Twist Off the
high board and you have to come up with
all this complicated crap because that's
what wealthy people do no they don't
they live on less than they make they
invest and they pay off their house and
if you want real money it's what they
really do build and sell a company
that's that's the American way that's
pretty cool now that's where most of
your billionaires come from
uh now if you want to study that's
Forbes 400 they're all today
billionaires and that's a thousand
million that's a different category
that's not a one to five million dollar
that's a thousand million you're not
gonna get a billionaire with your 401k
boys and girls mathematically impossible
okay but you you know so there's some
other tricks involved some things
involved but none of them are the
stupidest but anyone can become a
millionaire is so much simpler
social media is where you're getting
your financial information even though
we're on there I'll just tell you it's a
struggle this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey show George Campbell host of
The George camel YouTube show where
snark is an art form
uh yeah you gotta check this out it's a
lot of fun we're having a great time the
feedback's a spiritual gift of yours a
snark thing thank you you've got this
down and I I highly respect people with
a heavy level of snarky it takes it
takes intelligence oh yeah you can't not
just anybody can do it at this level so
it's it's a professional professional
grades well the feedback's been awesome
they're saying I'm like a young Dave
Ramsey whoa yeah if you were with much
better hair my age with hair this is
what you get that's what you'd get check
it out yeah wow I'm more I'm more of a
blunt instrument yours is very uh
speaking of which the uh the government
has at it again you were telling me Dave
while you were gone things happened
while I was gone where did that go I
don't know where you were but Jade and I
were hosting the show and I swear I got
1400 people sent me this on Instagram
and there was big headlines on the news
that Biden Administration made big
changes to mortgage rates and the high
credit good credit borrowers were going
to pay the price to allow the riskier
borrowers to get a discount okay so the
rest of your borrowers are getting a
better rate not not at the pay up charge
as much and this is socialized mortgage
so that the uh the people who did a good
job are going to support the people that
didn't do a good job with a uh by having
a higher rate on the good job people and
a lower rate on the bad job people is
this how it works that sounds about
right so here's the thing sounds like
socialism I'm in yeah okay yes and this
is Progressive there's misinformation
too so the low score folks no they're
still paying more for their mortgages
but the Gap has shrunk okay so to do
that they've increased the rate for the
good score folks they've decreased the
rate for the bad score folks but the
punch line is
that the actual rate change
on all of these people
is somewhere around an eighth of a
percent eighth to a quarter is what
we're actually going to see what we're
seeing according to the mortgage
industry okay translation Washington
just announced that they helped all the
poor people and beat up on the rich
people
and once again they did absolutely
nothing
they may they made they blew trumpets as
if they were going into battle
and they didn't even have a BB gun it
amounts to about 10 bucks a month per
100 000 changes your life it absolutely
changed your life if you have a low
credit score Joe Biden just changed your
life bullcrap
bullcrap these people this is in the
same bucket of I'm gonna pay off your
student loans when when pray tell old
Joe old Joe when are you going to do
this pray tell
seriously not much time left
I'm old but he makes old a whole new
thing yeah wow
so here's the thing Dave that people
don't understand if you follow the
Ramsay advice which Dave has been
preaching from the mountaintops for 30
years now guess what this doesn't affect
15-year loans which is the only loan
that's who it doesn't affect you because
if you're following us will you tell you
never take out more than a 15-year
mortgage and never more than a payment
of a Fourth of your take-home pay and
always put down a good down payment and
this program has absolutely no effect on
that at all by the way if you have zero
credit score it doesn't affect you at
all you're going to get the same great
rate you always got which is a premium
rate uh on a zero credit score so if
you're doing the Ramsay stuff uh you
avoided socialism
if you can be mad at the political stuff
all day but financially sleep easy at
night philosophically though you can't
even really be pissed off because he
really didn't do anything it's too much
again too much if you'll pay attention
to the actual dollars that these
programs that are supposed to save you
coming from Washington create the actual
dollars
then you will realize that these people
talk like they are doing something and
they never do anything and that's true
of the Republicans too by the way so I
mean that's just politics you live in
Washington your goal is to make a big
deal out of nothing and act like you did
something so that we all go oh I love
them I'm going to vote for them again
they took care of me you know one of the
worst hate I got and I still think
there's a Reddit entire Reddit thread on
hating Dave Ramsey on this was remember
when uh Trump came out with the uh covet
bucks and then Biden we had Biden bucks
also in the both of them did it uh and
they and that's one of them I can't
remember which it was so they gave out
thirteen hundred dollars you're gonna
everybody's gonna get thirteen hundred
dollars
and I was on Fox News and I said if
thirteen hundred dollars changes your
life you really don't have a life
oh Ramsay he's out of touch with the
real people Ramsay doesn't understand
it's just listen if thirteen hundred
dollars changes your life you don't have
a life
honestly we're gonna get canceled again
Dave what are you trying to do here I
mean it might feed you this week it
might pay your light bill for a week but
at the end of the month you're still
screwed
if you if if you go wow I got the
lottery oh God quick buy Mama house I
got 1300 bucks you know I mean is that
just a dumber in crap it's a it's a very
temporary Band-Aid on a bigger problem
it lasts about a minute and a half
and so truly if mathematically it's not
a philosophical statement it's not an
old Rich Boomer doesn't understand you
stupid butt people seriously that's just
dumb okay thirteen hundred dollars
mathematically doesn't change your life
a quarter of a percent an eighth of a
percent change in your mortgage one way
or the other does not change your life
and if you're being wise in the way
you're taking out a mortgage or you're
not taking out a mortgage at all guess
how much it affected my interest rate
zero
zero I am immune to socialism wow wow
because I don't borrow money you don't
play the game of the system and you
don't have to win the stupid prizes of
the system amazing how that works wow
I'm serious this is but I
yeah yeah I mean we announced we you
know when we announced um that we were
going to forgive student loans right
when we before election
and then promptly did nothing for a year
and a half a year and eight months but
in August prior to the midterms an
executive order is issued to forgive the
student loans that's Us timing as the
kids and it says
no doubt that was sussy it was very
sassy
they dangle the carrot to try to get the
vote and they do nothing and they and
here's the thing people call us and they
say well Dave why would I pay off my
loans why would I the government causes
only ten thousand dollars and oh by the
way have you noticed it has never
freaking happened
did you notice that part
did you notice that it's like I promised
it's a political promise how how old do
you have to be before you understand all
this is not going to happen I mean what
we need it we need to we need we need to
distribute little vials of cynicism to
this generation and let them become
cynical about Washington like the old
people have and because we are suspect
of everything they do there because it
is all for show and not for doe I mean
it doesn't change your life I've been
doing this a long time I've been for 30
years I've been coaching America on how
to build wealth and for 30 I still am
waiting on Washington to change my life
I get up every morning I say Lord
Lord Jesus when is Washington going to
change my life does he even answer that
one no he's not he's like he's getting
better he's still laughing he's just it
is a trick even if it's a promise or
something that actually happens like
this mortgage situation it's not
changing your life yeah so if it's all
over the news and you know fox has acted
like it's a socialist conspiracy coming
out of the way it's a good talking point
well they're trying to you know burn
down the White House because Biden
changed the mortgage thing with a stroke
of a pen it really changes it's like 10
bucks and everybody that gets a 15-year
mortgage it doesn't apply to you and so
you know it's it's it's irrelevant
it didn't once again hot air no
substance you know that's just it's just
full it's like a Chinese spa balloon I
mean it's just hot air no sections right
down it's just more crap well and it's
more reason to follow the Ramsay plan
because if you follow it you don't have
to worry about the one what the next
headline is going to be in the next
mortgage rate you just sleep better at
night going all right I'm gonna get a
15-year loan pay it off and then by the
way Trump didn't get rid of fouchy
either so I mean it's not like he's a
savior okay so you can be mad at me if
you're a lefty or a righty or whatever
just all of you get in line right but
the bottom line is if you're waiting on
the White House to fix your life let me
give you a hint the secret is not in the
White House the secret is in your house
get yourself a mirror look in the mirror
and go you the problem and you the
solution because that's where your help
is going to come from boys and girls
it's not coming from the Island of
Misfit Toys this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the law Lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt-free stage Brooke
is with us hey Brooke how are you hi I'm
good how are you better than I deserve
where do you live Pittsburgh ah welcome
to Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off Brooke 78 000 good for you how
long did that take about four years good
for you and your range of income during
that time 26 000 of 270 70 000. wow nice
jump what do you do for a living I'm a
registered nurse okay what was the 26
that wasn't nursing um I was a ticket
agent at an airline okay and you
finished nursing school and boom boom
yes so you got a much much better career
yes not that ticket agent is a horrible
thing but you make a lot more money now
yes yeah good for you so 78 000 was what
kind of debt
um your typical debt I started off going
to the university not really knowing
what I wanted to do changing my major so
a lot of the debt was about
um 42 000 of living on campus and old
phones
um 4 000 was between two credit
and 12 000 was a car loan so you were
just fairly normal yes broke yes and
then the additional 20 000 um I I paid
cash for the rest of my nursing school
okay when did you uh when did you
graduate nursing school and pasture bars
um 2021. okay so two years ago so
halfway through this program boom income
goes way up yes and we've knocked this
finish it off yes I'm suspecting the
majority of this was done in the last
two years the majority yes but I
I'm making like lemon
spots good for you so how'd you get tied
into this Ramsey stuff um um well
somebody actually tried to hand me your
book when I was working as a ticket
agent and I just honestly I should um I
set it on a shelf I was like who's Dave
Ramsey
um why are you bothering me yeah yeah I
was like trying to give you a ticket
yeah and um eventually like when I was
working as an agent I was just like
living paycheck to paycheck I couldn't
keep up with anything
um I was always like getting down to
zero that's when I got the credit cards
and I started putting my money on the
credit cards and everything
um and then I picked up the book again
and I was like I really need to start
paying off my debt so that's when I
started the baby steps um and just
worked gazelle intense since then okay
so you picked the book up and really
that's when it took off yeah so but you
had to get to a point where you felt
enough pain to go all right I'll try
anything all right here's this book
that's been collecting dust let's see
what it has to say exactly and it made
sense to you yes so a customer randomly
handed it to you yeah something nice yes
because ticket agents take more abuse
than just about anybody on the planet
yeah it was a very hard there's some
nasty human beings when it comes to
ticket agents yeah and I was doing it in
Washington DC oh yeah that'll gather
some really nasty humans okay some
arrogant nasty humans yeah so I'm
serious I have what for 27 000 a year
you took a lot of crap I didn't yeah
whoa who would yeah let's go ahead and
just say it who were you working for
which airline yes oh my gosh I've worked
for American Airlines that's okay we're
mad at America it's not their fault it's
the customer I mean boys and girls if
you're going up to the ticket agent and
you're an American Airlines person and
you're really pissed off because the
pilot screwed up or the mechanic screwed
up and your flight is delayed it is not
the twenty seven thousand dollar your
employees fault at the counter have some
class and be nice okay now here we go we
just took up for you we got the old you
the old you yes the new you is a
successful nurse in debt free yes I'm so
proud of you yeah and I also did um like
on the side I did Uber Eats doordash
instacart I walk dogs for wag I cleaned
Apartments I I went through like
um the apartment complex and found old
things refurbished them and sold them
wow out of all the side hustles what
made you the most money oh well um being
a nurse working full-time you could get
extra hours well yeah and I also had uh
it's called PRN nursing where you can
it's like you don't have benefits but
you can pick up extra and you get a
higher hourly rate so I did that at one
point I worked um 16 days in a row like
yeah just between like both jobs
um it was yeah
OT or PRN Big Time best best gig yeah
yeah yeah for sure yeah good and I got
to watch a lot of dogs too that was one
of my favorites some people would go
away on their trips having fun spending
money I was getting to play with dogs
and make some extra money too there it
is what do you charge for dog sitting
dog walking
um it just depends any like anywhere
like an hour walk like thirty dollars
it's amazing versus like a weekend maybe
like people are out there complaining
going Dave there's no work to do no side
hustles I want to do something from home
and you went and busted your butt and
was making 25 30 40 bucks an hour yeah
yeah I did a lot of side hustles oh good
for you was it worth it it was so worth
it I'm just emotional right now
yeah really it's it's crazy it just
occurs to me that these rich people pay
money to go to the gym and they pay her
to walk their dog
it's amazing it's just coming through
well if the exercise is free yeah we
know that yeah when you go to the gym
and you can't get a parking spot close
to the door you're gripe right so I mean
this is how this is how backward we are
okay just just yeah way to go thank you
how's it feel to be free
um liberating it's just you have to once
you experience it like you don't really
realize like how great you're gonna feel
um my whole life has changed and I know
like my whenever I have a family like
their life's gonna change too so I'm
proud of it outside of money what were
those changes you would say here's what
I'm I've experienced oh my God thanks to
debt Freedom just like you guys were
talking about previously just like
accountability and like looking at
yourself in the mirror and being like
you're the problem you have to fix it
you know you can't depend on anyone else
and I actually have something so funny
to share
um you're gonna be kind of disappointed
but you know when they were offering the
refunds like if you paid off student
loans during covid which is what I took
a big advantage of that zero interest
that's when I was really going to
hammered it instead instead of standing
back waiting yeah that's good yeah but
what I did I I actually was like well
maybe I can get that 20 000 they're
gonna pay it like I just paid all this
money off so I got my money refunded
back to me all of it it hit my bank
account and I was like oh my gosh I'm
rich
and I was like no I'm not that's like
dead that's all dead so my loans got
reinstated I had the money back to me
and I just had this like guilt Shadow
like over my whole body and I'm like
Brooke what are you doing you just spent
four years like building up this whole
new character like all these like traits
that you didn't have before like the
sacrifice the dedication the taking the
accountability it's saying no to people
all this stuff and I was like I was like
you are paying that debt so that like
once it came back into my account I was
like
don't depend on the government you have
to do this now like they're never gonna
pay that and so then the next day I paid
it and I paid it again yes yeah I did
you got two dead friends yeah I did yeah
because well that's good that's good I
like that they're not gonna be good for
you yeah well you got you trained you
changed who you are and so you changed
the way you talk to yourself yeah
nothing's gonna stop you now yeah no
challenge no you're amazing heard Dr
John deloney the other day you said if
anyone talk to me the way I talked to me
I would hit them you know yeah so but
you're changing all the negative self
the opposite so who was cheering you on
um my my best friend and my fiance were
two really big cheerleaders um they're
here with me today
um but I I actually had a lot more
people telling me I was crazy than I had
supporting me but I just that's for you
on or hold you back I just tuned them
out I'm like yeah I know you guys are
all broke and you have so much debt and
you have like six credit cards and like
I'm not gonna listen to you you guys
friends are making fun of your financial
plan you're right on track yeah exactly
yeah good for you and soon they're going
to be asking you hey uh what was they oh
by the way Brooke exactly yeah Brooke
what was that thing you were doing yeah
Money Makeover I tried so much to talk
about it and people just be like not
wanting to listen I'm like if I could
have took the younger me when the person
like handed me the book I probably would
have like had them smack me in the head
with it like can you just follow these
steps because your life will change like
it will truly change
we're not recommending matching people
with my books
okay now good job listen well done hey
we got a copy of the baby steps
Millionaire's book for you The Total
Money Makeover book and so you can hand
those out and uh a subscript or a
membership to Financial Peace University
if you've not been through that go ahead
and go through it if you have then give
it away and we want you to continue on
this journey and become a baby steps
millionaire and then we want you on the
baby steps millionaire hour okay you're
gonna be there you're gonna be there I'm
proud of you how old are you I'm 30.
excellent very very well done all right
Brooke from Pittsburgh
partly ticket agent partly successful
nurse partly a dog walker 78 thousand
dollars paid off in four years because
she changed Brooke I'm so proud of you
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
yeah baby
I think it's so cool that we can just
change you see that emotion you see that
emotion oh yeah yeah couldn't hardly get
it out
this is what happens when you change
your life be not conformed to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing of your mind this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
foreign
debt smart saving and investing is smart
being generous is smart protecting your
finances from emergencies
people Overlook that all the time
there's 10 kinds of insurance coverage
you might need based on what your life
looks like today and we built a coup
tool called the coverage checkup tool
and hey we want you to check that out
it's completely free to use and we can
connect you with Ramsey trusted
insurance providers and make sure you
get your plan in place really fast
seriously could be the most important
five minutes you spend so go to
ramsesolutions.com
checkup it's a free five-minute program
the coverage checkup tool make sure you
get rid of the gimmick insurance and
keep the right kinds of insurance and
don't overpay for the right kinds of
insurance but hey you got to play
defense and offense to win the game
insurance is defense
so not having that will break your butt
ramseysolutions.com slash
checkup
also ladies and gentlemen a whole bunch
of you are new to the show we know that
based on our ratings increase and our
rankings increase as well so thank you
for joining us we're glad you're here
and if you want to if you're having
trouble might be understanding some of
the uh I don't know the vernacular the
Ramsey tribe lingo then uh hey we'll
teach you baby steps and debt snowballs
and all that kind of stuff go to
ramsesolutions.com click on the GSA the
the get started button the get started
button it is free and it will get you
some help and show you where you are and
where you can go next and all that kind
of good stuff Bill's in Chicago hey Bill
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dan hey Dave George thanks for uh
taking my call real quick just wanted to
say thanks for what uh you and your team
do it's truly life-changing well thank
you sir how can we help yeah I have two
questions that might be related but uh
because I'm a little older uh we're
maxing out my 401k uh should we keep
doing that or do step six kind of as
written and how much should we put
toward College savings
so what's your percentage right now
going into your investing
uh right now about 25 of
um of uh uh gross salary okay so if you
dial that back down how old are you
oh 50. I'll be 50 next month oh you're
ancient okay time is running out
and where where's your nest tag at right
now
uh total retirement is 173 000
thereabouts okay
so if we dial that back let's say to 15
how much more money would that give you
every month to put away for college and
throw at the house
uh that would give me an extra 15 uh
an extra oh wait about an extra 1500 a
month okay yeah and so voila we just
funded college and started paying down
the house because you're going to be
okay you're gonna be okay on your wealth
building side but you need to get the
house paid off and of course we've got
to save for college or the next
generation is going to be having to uh
you know consider student loans which we
don't even want on the table that's not
even an option
how old are the kids
uh well they're kind of a little spread
out I got a 17 year old and a
nine-year-old so I've got a junior who's
coming up to college and then um uh you
know nine-year-old has got some time so
your likely cash flow in the Junior
because you got nothing in there we do
have about 35 000 aside for him
um some of it then yeah okay yeah yeah
that'll be gone in a year easy or sure
depending on what the situation is year
and a half anyway so then you got to
catch up with the rest of it and then
we've got to start thinking about the
nine-year-old so it doesn't put the
squeeze on us later and so yeah you just
back into the math on how much of the
1500 goes towards the uh the College
Plan
and uh it's probably a lot of it you're
probably not putting a lot extra on the
house but four five and six should be
done simultaneously you are not making
ground by putting all of this into
retirement and nothing in college and
nothing on the house because if you
don't address these other things they're
gonna come up and hit you in the back of
the head
yeah okay gotcha yeah you gotta you got
to get it all up and that's why we run
four five and six simultaneous and once
you have a paid for house and the kids
college is covered well now we have a
whole lot more money to catch up on
wealth building as well but you don't
even have to because he's gonna I mean
it's only 50 he's got 200 000 already he
keeps putting 15 in 10 more years he's
gonna have a million dollars a million
and a half dollars in his 401k when it
gets to 65 now it's 15 years yeah so um
with what he's putting in at 15 with
that and uh and then we take care of
kids college and in 15 years get the
house paid off then he's going to be
sitting at 65 probably worth four or
five million dollars
so uh but if you don't do this then
you've got a mess at college and you're
going to bump up on 65 and still be
looking down the throat of a mortgage
and so that that's why we do this this
way we've actually
developed the system as he said buy the
book but the book is not just some
random series of thoughts it's uh highly
developed and Polished over 30 years of
helping 10 million people in our
millionaire study we also found that
they get paid for houses and they paid
off fast they don't pay it off in 30
years right they pay it off an average
of 10.2 exactly Susan's in Chicago hi
Susan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you very much sure what's up
um I am trying to figure out if I should
continue to try and space for grad
school while I'm finishing up paying
down my debt or if I should
um
use what I have saved to pay uh on my
debt and then start over basically
um what are you going to study in grad
school
I I would like to go away to study uh
curation and conservation for probably
art history uh could be human artifacts
too
and that's going to cost what
uh when I do the research it looks like
it can range between 20 and 30 000
depending on the school okay
this sounds like it's a a passion area
have you actually looked at what you
make as a result of doing this
uh so it can vary a lot on what type and
the size of the museum you work in if
it's somewhere small and local it could
be down to 40 000 if you work at the
Metro the Smithsonian it could be in six
figures what are you doing now
uh right now I work for the airlines
repairing medical equipment when they
damage it
what do you make now
I make sixty thousand a year as of
January I just get a promotion that came
with a raise awesome okay
and then I have a side job that is
closer to the passion
um I got hired on by my alma mater to be
an assistant in their art collection and
that started in February and I make uh
between 560 and 700 a month depending on
the number of hours I can work
okay
and how much debt do you have
uh left I have 47 000 even
um
all right the math that you just gave me
says that your degree the expense that
you're the money you're spending on your
degree has a return on investment of
increasing your income of very close to
zero
yeah it depends on where I go yeah yeah
and so I mean smithsonian's like a
fairly small percentage of the jobs
yeah no no
no no I mean you're making more now than
you would make at an entry-level job
after getting the degree
yes and so spending twenty thousand
dollars to get a degree to make the same
or less is a zero rate of return
is what I'm saying yeah so this is a
hundred percent this is a hundred
percent Passion Play It's not a return
on investment play which is okay but
that just helps you decide which one you
want to do first and that tells me get
out of debt first
because the school um has always been
payoff first and then go to grad school
it's just trying to figure out when to
save the money to go yeah uh after you
get out of debt
you have any money saved now
um I have about 30 30 or sorry
3600 ish in savings at the moment and I
have a three thousand dollar tax return
coming from the Feds that I didn't
anticipate yeah we suggest to people
work what we call the baby steps and the
first step is reduce all savings that
you have down to one thousand dollars so
I'm gonna use a tax return and twenty
six hundred dollars to throw at your
forty seven thousand dollars worth of
debt and then I'm gonna put my budget on
beans and rice rice and beans no life
I'm gonna work all the time and I'm
gonna attack this remaining forty
thousand and get it paid off as soon as
possible when it's paid off then I will
save up the money to uh get the degree
to move towards your passion that is not
going to change your income
dramatically it might change it a little
might change it negatively but it might
change it a little positively but it's
not going to get there's not going to be
an Roi you're not spending twenty
thousand to make 200 000 you're spending
twenty thousand to get into your field
that's what you're doing this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work
that they love and create actual real
amazing relationships open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five George Campbell Ramsay
personality is my co-host today he is
the host of the new extremely popular
YouTube channel the George camel with a
K YouTube channel you gotta check it out
he's also the co-host of the very
popular podcast and YouTube show uh
smart money happy hour with Rachel Cruz
and so both are happening right now and
you can check them all out open phones
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five Michael's in Washington D.C
hey Michael how are you
hey Dave doing great thanks for having
me sure man what's up
uh so about a month ago my son had an
asthma attack and um ended up getting
airlifted out uh by helicopter and we're
trying to figure out if he's doing fine
now but we're trying to figure out if we
uh stop paying on the car we were going
to have paid off in September or put
money into a savings account to kind of
prepare for the bills that were that we
know are kind of they're starting to
trickle in but we don't know the exact
total yet uh lifelike covered by your
health insurance
it the the Val it's still pending but
they think it's going to be yeah there's
no reason it shouldn't be covered
sometimes it doesn't and when the bird
flop when the bird flies it's 10 grand
minimum
yeah yeah that's what we're kind of
waiting on we have an out of pocket
maximum on the health plan
um 8500 so I talked to the insurance
company they they think it's going to be
covered but we don't know until we get
the actual explanation benefits in so
what's the worst case on this is you're
out of pocket max it should be yeah it
should be 8 500. how much money do you
guys have right now in savings
uh about 11.
okay so this thing's covered completely
either way but you get the car to pay
off what's left on the car
15. and that's all the debt
yep
okay so we're gonna throw the 11 at the
car or you know some of that most of
that uh at the car probably soon and
that's where we're gonna pay it off in
September but now with this yeah I think
I think you're going to cover the 8500.
I mean you got to build your nose coming
and so we're just gonna we're gonna
earmark your savings 8 500 uh and then
we're just going to attack the car with
cash flow and as long as as long as it
doesn't come in over 8 500 then that'll
be a perfect plan right
yeah yeah I would just delay the car a
little bit but that's that's what yeah
but that's you know yeah if you had to
make that choice you'd make it because
and you did to take care of your child
right yep absolutely yeah and so uh was
he out was he remote or something and
couldn't get his breath what was the
story
yeah he we just kind of found out that
he had some asthma issues recently
within the last like probably four or
five months and then he had he got a
cold and it turned into a pretty severe
asthma attack and we took him to the
local hospital and they
um transferred into The Children's
Hospital pretty quickly by a helicopter
so um It All Happened pretty quickly
yeah wow scary
yeah it's good it's good that he's okay
how old is he
he's five uh-huh that's super scary then
it was very scary yeah very scary so
well I'm glad he's okay I'm glad he's
okay I'm glad it's only that you got
good health insurance in place
um and uh yeah this was not an ER thing
it's just not where you were in a remote
setting and they had to fly a Life
Flight to you this was hospital to
hospital transfer so that may fall in
the insurance differently in a good way
um so yeah because I've I've run into
over the years too many times that
health insurance did not cover Life
Flight flying to a rural situation to
pick someone up and then flying them you
know uh 50 miles out of town or
something like that where you can't get
an ambulance to him right that kind of
thing is a different different thing but
I'm so glad everything's okay what's
your household income
a hundred and thirty thousand okay all
right yeah so you just it just did you
know it's just a a it's a speed bump a
bump in the road that delays everything
and uh and it's one you didn't choose
but uh but we're glad the baby's okay
and yeah you just just play it through
yeah take set 8 500 aside out of the
savings and then attack the car as fast
as you can after that and just be
thankful that you're able to do all of
it you know wow it'll be debt free
either way in a few months so yeah
there's nothing
um it's one thing to get sick it's
another thing for your kid to be sick
you just it uh you feel so uh helpless
I'll tell you even worse grandkids sick
oh because you're not even allowed to to
raise hell I mean you can't you can't
you know you have to have the parents
ratio I mean where's the nurse you know
you can't do that right you just have to
stand back and because they had you know
you can't do that so you gotta stop
today be quiet that's called Boundaries
apparently that might have happened you
know it might have happened so is that
Rachel I can't tell whose voice that was
I'm I'm not gonna say I'm not gonna say
I'm not gonna because they were right
and I was wrong so we're not going to
throw anybody on the bus but Dave yeah
so smart man yeah it's just this it's
hot but it's man it takes it it no
Health says it takes your breath away
you cannot say this kid had asthma so
but um but yeah this is uh yeah it you
can't um and it's you're known for those
over 30 years I've done this repeatedly
Anthony is with us in uh New Jersey hey
Anthony how are you
hi thank you for having me sure how can
we help
all right so I had a situation with
looking to get some advice
um basically when I was 18 or 19 years
old I'm 22 right now
um I had an online business and I was
able to accumulate a good amount of
capital and with the help of my parents
I invested in two real estate uh
Ventures I got a a little house that I
rent out and then I got a shopping strip
um the how the house pays about three
thousand dollars a month and the
shopping strip pays about ten thousand
dollars a month
um so you're 22 you have a thirteen
thousand dollar a month rental income
yeah
odd how much money did you make with
your online business
three million wow so impressive
and bizarre yes
wait say it again sorry impressive and
bizarre and wonderful
thank you uh so my my situation comes
where next year
um the mortgage I got uh it was about
two to three million dollars and you
took out a mortgage
now so so right now
um it we paid we paid about 8.50 for it
uh I put 400 down and then the rest we
did a private mortgage where's the rest
of your money
oh hold on I'm gonna get to that okay so
all right so
um like I said we paid 400 for it
um
down and then we put the yeah down and
then we put the Reps in the mortgage and
the mortgage will be paid off next year
um so after that like I said the 13 000
will be completely you know no payments
no debt no nothing because the house I
mentioned we paid full in cash okay now
when I when I was talking about the two
to three million I was just taking into
account like all my assets because from
2019 when we bought the property to now
it's gone up that much just looking at
no but your online business how much did
your online business make okay online
business it was it was about like eight
hundred thousand to a million okay and
use 400 for the down payment here and
you use some for the other where's the
rest of that money taxes I have I have I
have a hundred thousand dollars in cash
okay I have about I have about fifty
thousand dollars in stocks and what's
your question then what are you wanting
to do so my question would be since I'm
very young
you know I'm very grateful for the you
know guaranteed monthly income but I was
wondering if it would be a good idea to
maybe you know once the private mortgage
is paid off to take out another mortgage
on it now and try to do something else
no no you've got good money you have a
brain an unusually good brain use it and
keep your keep your properties paid for
and let that be your base of operation
do not take out another debt
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you are here we are constantly
asking you guys and a bunch of you have
we appreciate you to leave a five-star
review
on the show it helps with the algorithms
and also of course we invite you to
share the show click the share button or
share a link or tell people where you
listen to it on the radio or whatever it
is and it's always a good idea too to
follow the show click the follow or the
subscribe on YouTube or on the podcast
all three of those help us a bunch and
uh we got a five star review in we've
gotten a bunch of men but this one
caught our team's attention I must admit
being left leaning from the West Coast
my entire life listening to the Ramsay
show came as quite the culture shock
it was it was hard for me to not
immediately associate the tone of the
show with a laundry list of cultural
values I've been conditioned to avoid
I kept listening anyway because I love
Dave straight talk it was super
refreshing and after a while it was
obvious he's in fact in fact a really
kind brilliant person that just wants to
instill some fiscal Common Sense back
into our society what I love most is how
he talks about the importance of
stewardship and how it's not just about
the money it's about how your money can
help the world amazing stuff uh jumping
past some of the personal story then
listening to these episodes makes me
acknowledge that I just need to be
accountable for my poor decisions and
stop feeling helpless I can get myself
out of this situation and it shouldn't
even be that hard I just have to make
some common sense tough choices and go
without for the next few years hi my
name is Eileen and I am irresponsible
with money I'm ready to put the work in
and be accountable for my own actions
and I will win at this game of life
passing these values down to my young
kids thank you to the bottom of my heart
for Dave and the entire team for
achieving what my parents have failed to
do my whole life getting me to be
fiscally responsible wow that's very
very nice thank you thank you yes very
kind I love that we appreciate you bring
in both sides of the aisle together Dave
yeah that's right I'm all about Unity
that's me that's amazing I'm I'm I'm I'm
honored I'm very honored very nice I'm
glad we are honored it's the whole the
whole team here it's a team effort open
phone's at triple eight eight two five
five two two five DJ is with us in
Baltimore Hey DJ what's up hey hey guys
um so I wanted to see if you had some
suggestions on how to approach a
situation
um that my husband and I are trying to
tackle so
um I'm about two years away from going
to Veterinary Medical School and I also
was diagnosed with an illness last year
um that kind of limits me quite a bit
and it also means that I have to
renovate our home in order to make it
work for my condition so we're trying to
figure out what's the best way to
approach paying for those two very high
cost things without putting ourselves
into a bind when we're not currently in
one
hmm so sorry
what's the nature of your illness
so I
I'm highly just
just to
interiors and molds to the point where
it causes my body to go into paralysis
so
um why does that sound extremely
incongruent to vet school to me
because it can be so I there's one
option for vet school it's a brand new
school being built in New Jersey
that would be preferable for me to be in
during I can't think of anything that
has more bacteria and mold than animals
[Applause]
it's the type of molds that would grow
like in your home due to water damage so
there's two different kinds okay so it's
basically issues with water damaged
buildings I got you okay
so you've got uh a a mold problem in
your current home
we bought our home in 2020 and it was an
extension how expensive to eradicate it
to be ready to sell
like about
five hundred thousand dollars no yeah
five hundred thousand dollars for mold
remediation no yeah not to make you
healthy to be ready to sell
to sell it yeah I mean you can't as far
as it doesn't take 500 000 to remediate
mold in anything
except an office tower
no but I just did it I just did it at my
lake house I spent three grand
yeah that's definitely not the bid set
we were quoted for sure I don't know I
mean this has a whole house eating up
with mold
Yeah so basically any of the water
sourced areas so all of the bathrooms
the kitchen and the basement
you need to get three more bids
because let me just tell you the mold
world is full of drama queens not you
I'm talking about the the contractors
that do eradication and they'll come in
and go
they do this and it's part of their
sales pitch they got it completely you
gotta start from scratch I got like five
beds on the lake house and they were
everything from three from uh one
thousand dollars which was incredible up
to thirty five thousand
yeah yeah
so like the beds are upper up between 40
and 6 her area
that we're looking at in our home to
remediate and then to renovate them yeah
I wouldn't stay there if I had yourself
I love you and as your brother I'm
telling you to move you shouldn't stay
there if you have a condition that
paralyzes you this house has got real
mold problems and so I don't know if we
I don't know if we're going to burn it
down or if we're going to sell it as is
to some investor who remediates it or we
find a better remediation thing but I
don't think this house is renovated for
you
you need to move
yeah I don't know
I don't know can you guys go rent
somewhere for now while you're dealing
with the selling of the home this
creates paralysis for you you said
yeah it scares me to death
I know it's it's really frustrating
because each and especially this region
that I live in like the Baltimore DC
area you know it's quite wet quite humid
um so I I really don't know where we
would go and but you also know you're
going to go to vet school in New Jersey
so it sounds like you need to move to
New Jersey if you're going to do that
so it's the it's a part of New Jersey
that's closer to where we live so it's
commutable for me yeah so you've
established here if you're going to go
this vet school you're going to stay in
the area
yeah and every house in Baltimore does
not have mold
you know that right
I hope not come on DJ
come on it's mainly I you know we love
we
yes I I understand what you're saying
but we do love our home and wouldn't
want to move if we didn't have to
because we just yeah long ago you have
to move you are not going to spend a
half million dollars is at stake
and this place is is apparently rotting
down with mold
I mean you can't stay there
and there are other houses in the
Baltimore area that don't have mold we
live in Co we live in uh hot damp
Tennessee which is worse than cold
Baltimore for for mold it's like mold is
a way of life in our area it's
everywhere and and it's not everywhere
it's not in every house my current home
does not have mold my lake house got
some underneath and it was three
thousand bucks to eradicate it so I mean
it's uh yeah you but you've got to get
and I've got a bunch of rental houses
and we've had a couple of those we had
to do some work on but I've never had
one that was completely rotted down with
mold that is not so but and I have had
some contractors and some tenants that
thought that it was because the drama
around this is it's never ending and I'm
not suggesting you have the Drama DJ if
you've got an illness that is mold and
you have an extreme mold situation in
your house and that is in conflict with
your health and in conflict with your
ability to go to uh to vet school sell
the house for what you can get for it
and go rent something and go to vet
school and have your health it's a real
simple program I would not be in the
mold renovation business if I had an
extreme illness related to mold
it's the last thing you want to do
because the more they tear into it the
more it stirs it up
you can't live there while you're doing
it anyway if it's a massive thing we
fall get you gotta leave you gotta do
all this stuff and so uh yeah
you might you can't have too many things
conflicting for one go we have three
goals Health housing and vet school
what takes Priority Health what's next
vet school what's next stupid house
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their why 100
percent satisfaction guarantee and
shipping is always free see why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings go
to blinds.com now and save 45 off
selected products visit blinds.com today
for more info
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Sarah
is with us hi Sarah welcome to the
Ramsay show hi Dave good to have you
where do you live I live in Raleigh
North Carolina Welcome to Nashville how
much data have you paid off twenty six
thousand seven hundred fifty dollars
love it how long did this take you eight
and a half months good for you and your
range of income during that time I
started with 42 and then I ended with
50. good for you what do you do for a
living I was an investing Communications
and now I'm in digital marketing good
for you very good what kind of debt was
your 27 000 it was in a car bad decision
um yeah I it was a lot of money and I
totally regretted it when I got into
that debt so did you sell it or did you
pay it off I ended up paying it off okay
and cap it all right good for you fun
what kind of car it is a Toyota RAV4
2015. of course it is okay good very
good cool so how'd you get connected to
all this Ramsey stuff I actually am a
Ramsay baby my mom and dad followed your
plan
um I didn't take their advice at first I
wish I did
um they failed as parents but they did
get me on the right track
no they didn't they told you knew what
to do you knew they weren't gonna like
what you did oh yeah they were not too
happy about it what was that
conversation like
um yeah I just took out a 27 000 car
payment again yeah they told me I should
get a beater until I can you know really
pay cash for it but you know I didn't
listen and you know they helped give me
advice to dig me out of the hole I was
in yeah and no money just advice they
didn't give you any money no money no
good for them I like it these are great
parents yeah they are very cool how old
are you I'm 20 I'm turning 26 in June
okay did you learn your lesson I did
never a car payment again never again
You're Gonna Be A Millionaire exactly if
you stay away from car payments you'll
be a millionaire I will what was your
car payment
um it was it started off around 600 and
then oh yeah so then I ended up putting
my savings down on it kind of followed
the plan of the book and then I brought
it down to 300 around 300. okay that's a
significant portion of your take-home
pay at that point yes it was really bad
and that's when he went this is I did um
let's undo this yeah
um I did have a good bit saved up
because you know my parents really
instilled in me I need to save save save
um I graduated college debt free thanks
to them following your plan
um and then so luckily I had some
savings to put down on it to really drop
the payments how much did you have in
savings 23
000. wow okay all right very good let's
throw eight and a half months later
we're done yeah yeah that's very good so
you actually had enough cash to pay for
a decent car I did you had the savings
muscle there I know but you went nah I'm
gonna Finance you just got the fever I
know I talked to too many friends and I
was like fever yeah you kind of got a
great car for 20 grand in cash I know
well it was also when the cars were
really overvalued too so it was really a
bad time for me worst time ever yeah
what did you what did what were you
driving at the time uh 2012 Chevy Cruze
okay yeah and it just blew up on me one
day oh and then you went to drama mode
and said I need a new car today yeah I
got to finance a 30 000 car yeah I made
some bad decisions hey I'm proud out of
you thank you we're giving you a hard
time but everybody's done a whole lot
Dumber things than you've done yeah the
good news is you did it at a very young
age and you learn your lesson you never
go back and you have parents who didn't
bail you out no helicopter blades in the
background here no one no no one uh you
know you let you lay in your mess and
clean it up and you did you became like
a full-grown woman and did your stuff
way to go how old are you again I'm 25
turning 26. you're smart way to go I'm
so proud of you thank you very well done
how's it feel to be free it feels
amazing I actually had to get a new tire
the other day and I wasn't freaking out
because I had money to pay for it yeah
like one car payment will buy tires yeah
one of the old car payments anyway yeah
good for you very cool okay now that
you've gotten out of debt uh
you've got a 24 year old listening that
all of these uh 23 year old listening
the 24. uh that their stupid friends are
telling them to go buy a car on car
payments when they got the money in
savings to buy a 15 or 20 000 car what
would you tell that person that was you
back then I would say do not go into
debt why we're appreciating assets why
why because it's a waste of money
yeah it'll drain your bank account
and it stole your piece yeah it it what
little bit of fun it was was all taken
away by the weight
wasn't it was yeah the weight the
heaviness that weight not the not having
to wait patiently in line but the
heaviness of it yeah that way to go wow
very good and the secret to getting out
of debt is what
um a lot of side jobs I found a lot of
side jobs doing like walking dogs pet
sitting house sitting
um I did some freelance work in
additional to my full-time sticking to a
budget and paying cash wow good for you
well done well done
smiling now they're smiling oh yeah yeah
now now it's gone it's all going good
now well most people listening are going
gosh I wish I figured this stuff out
when I was 25 and you're feeling like I
wasted all this time and there's no you
got so much time left to make good
decisions that will far displace the 37
year old listen that we're still not
listening that we're still not convinced
they're about to go get a new car
they're gonna be 42 before they catch on
yeah way to go good job very good job
very good job hey we've got a copy of
the baby steps millionaires book for you
because that's your future that's where
you're headed I promise you you are 600
a month you know how fast you'll be a
millionaire real fast just investing
that it's serious money and uh Total
Money Makeover book as well hand that
out to one of your friends and go don't
do it and uh you know the same stuff
your parents did but yeah that's okay so
it's smart very smart and a Financial
Peace University membership have you
been through the class as an adult yet I
have not good you could take it and go
through it okay go through the nine
lessons and uh because it'll help you
accelerate your process into millionaire
now because you got the basic debt stuff
figured out and the budgeting and the
hard work and the extra jobs part so now
we just blow through make sure you get
the emergency fund in place and let's
let's get that compound interest working
for you at 25 years old you could be
worth 10 or 15 million dollars at
retirement you really could it's very
very doable uh I mean because you got
the right start you got it you got this
in you know a financial piece baby you
got everything going 40 Years of
investing in compound interest yeah so
the two the two books and the Financial
Peace University membership is the live
and give bundle that is uh people buy it
all the time it's a box that comes and
you can take a book out for yourself
give a book to a friend take financial
peace or give it to a friend so it's
live and give it's for both things and
so we'll give it all to you thanks for
making the trip over from Raleigh you're
inspiring you're a wonderful young woman
thank you for having me I'm very well
done and your mom and dad are over there
grinning like they know you're not going
to move in your their basement yeah it's
great it's amazing so very cool very
cool stuff good stuff all right it's
Sarah from Raleigh North Carolina she
paid off the car she shouldn't have
bought and she learned a lesson in the
process 27 000 paid off in eight and a
half months including using some for
savings and walking dogs 42 to 50 000
income counted down let's hear a debt
free scream hey three two one I'm dead
dude
[Applause]
we love to see it
I'm I think we need to do an informal
survey on how many rev fours
it's just something about a RAV4 right
that's come up a lot lately
a lot of calls I've taken it's a very
popular vehicle for young broke people
yeah and it's one they go well it's
worth it it's a safe reliable great car
I'll have a long time I'll Finance it
you know
that's the theory the center of gravity
on that thing is really high
I watched one do a flip oh really so
that's scary forward flip wow yeah so um
yeah I mean I just I'm not against rev
Force it's just I just I'm seeing that
your truck will eat a RAV4 I know like
you want to be in a monster truck but I
don't yeah but that's that's that's not
the point it's um it would it would also
eat your Tesla but it would spit it back
out so it can't handle the battery Dave
it can't eat that thing no gag right on
the battery just that battery will last
forever battery acid in your throat
people we justify car purchases all the
time especially younger we all do we all
do you know people do it yeah it's safe
it's reliable I did I work hard I don't
want to drive the beater around but
listen freedom on the other side of that
let me show you fifteen thousand dollars
is not a beater
that's not 1500 is a beater yeah okay so
wow but she's she's great she's amazing
she's gonna do so good big things I hope
she inspired a lot of other people out
there to go I'm gonna be like her I
don't want a car payment that's right
she just I mean people who will stand up
and look in the mirror and go done
that's inspiring that's inspiring this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host okay let's
clear something up if you listen to the
show for 10 seconds you know we hate
that and some people for some reason
don't understand that I don't know why
they think you need debt and credit
cards to build your credit yeah well you
do why would you want to build your
credit so you can go into debt and and
why would you go into debt so you could
build your credit and then why would you
go into that so you could build your
credit why would you build your credit
so you could go into debt because you
need a good credit score to buy a house
right no you do not the truth is living
a debt-free lifestyle eventually you
won't have any credit score and you got
to find a good lender like Churchill
Mortgage it can do what's called manual
underwriting George and Whitney did that
for their home and uh they survived zero
credit score and you've got a uh the
same rate as someone with a good credit
score when you did it so you don't have
to pay more and you need to get a real
estate agent who will actually help you
find a house that you can afford on a
15-year
fixed rate with a good strong down
payment and a payment of no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay all of that
can happen at Ramsey trusted
yeah woke up with a good real estate
agent that knows what they're doing high
octane high protein that gets it done I
meet them all over this nation when I'm
traveling we were just in Salt Lake City
we talked to a bunch of them uh good
quality people I'm always
I'm always inspired by the fact that the
our team has done a good job to put the
quality of person they put in our ELP
program so you want to find out who's
Ramsay trusted to help you with your
real estate transaction click on that at
ramseysolutions.com agent our question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
when you're trying to get things done
around your house sometimes you need to
run into a problem or a project that's
more than you can handle yourself
neighborly.com is your source for the
best Pros in your area to help with Home
Improvement projects great company
neighborly today's question comes from
Zach in Alabama he asks I'm reading more
and more about D dollarization and
countries moving away from the US dollar
as their basis of international trade
will this affect the strength of a
dollar and should I be concerned about
how I'm saving and investing as a result
of this
number one Zach you're spending too much
time on the internet
first and foremost okay
because you've gotten into the
conspiracy theory blanks here now what
is really going on okay I'm I'm
concerned with how it's going let me see
moving away from the US dollar as their
basis of international trade let me just
tell you
China and Brazil and Russia are the
three main players in this
they already don't use the US dollar
as their basis of international trade
Russia has its own currency so does
China and so does Brazil and there's a
conversion rate between that currency
and the US dollar
so many dollars equals so many in okay
and uh you know when you go to Mexico
a whole bunch of pesos equals a dollar
right like 20 of them so um
that's you know you got a conversion
rate from one currency to another what
these particular the three largest
countries and they're talking about
bringing in some of the oil countries as
well in the Middle East uh are doing is
they're trying to come up with one
currency that they all use
and then that would be an international
trade converted back and forth to
Dollars much like Europe did with the
euro
which by the way
kinda didn't work
when that we had this exact same crap
when you're when uh
you know France did away with their own
currency
the uh brexit was the big deal whether
the UK was going to get involved or not
and the Euro was traded all over Europe
and they did away with their basic
currency and now the U.S is just going
to have we're gonna it's a One World
Currency it's the end times of
Revelation and this is what comes up
right okay but all it is is these
countries if they did all agree to use
one currency it'd be much like one
Europe went to the euro and then that's
going to exchange for the dollar back
and forth are those countries going to
be able to devalue the Dollar by doing
that no
because while they do take up a lot of
land mass they do not take up a lot of
the gross domestic product of the world
the United States still is the vast
majority of the gross domestic product
of the world still
China is Big Russia is basically
horrible and Brazil is in a failed
economy like times 10 and it's tiny as
far as economics go in other words like
I I suspect I haven't looked it up but I
suspect Texas has a higher GDP than
Brazil
as an example for real I'm not kidding I
haven't looked it up but I bet you
that's true look it up I know it's got a
higher GDP than Egypt because I looked
that up one time I know it's got a
higher GDP than uh Sweden and about five
of the other countries that were talking
about natural gas crap a few years ago
because I looked that one up and that
was going to be the end of the world and
they were going to take over but they're
tiny butt little countries
and so when you put them all together
they don't have the muscle to take down
the dollar they just don't
mathematically it's arithmetic you know
you can't they just don't have it now
what they are going to do if they all do
put it together it's not a d
dollarization it's not doing away with
the dollar they've created their own
currency they're still going to have to
trade with the 800 pound gorilla which
be us
okay and you're gonna have to trade with
us in dollars so you're gonna whatever
little currency you create over there in
your little fantasy world that you live
in you're still going to have to trade
it for dollars
so it's not going to take down the
dollar is not going to be worth anything
and I don't know how to invest because
it's going to collapse because freaking
Brazil Brazil
seriously Brazil
I mean when you look at the math it's
humorous I mean in Russia we always
think of is like you know the in the
Rocky movies or something like they're
going to come bomb the United States or
whatever and all this stuff but they're
when you look at their even though it's
a huge landmass their economic
production is pitiful
it's pitiful because communism sucks and
so it just doesn't create a lot of gross
domestic product you know and and so
really when you get into it that's what
you're going to find so I'm am I worried
about this absolutely not absolutely
zero should you because Russia is
pitiful China has no labor force their
labor force is aging out because they
they stopped having babies
legally you know and so they have no
young labor force coming on so about
several economists are predicting that
their economy is really going to be in
deep due to in 20 years because there's
going to be nobody to work
nobody do the work and so all the stuff
that they're China's creating right now
they're not going to have anybody to do
it
and so this is a lot of just
fear-mongering it's it's it gets clicks
and Views and so the media loves it gets
a lot of clicks but should you be
concerned about how you're saving and
investing no no I wouldn't change a
thing nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope I wouldn't bet against
America long term it's a bad thing and
it's not it's not arrogance it's math
it's not like I'm blinded by the flag or
patriotism that's not it America does
some stupid butt stuff sometimes but uh
but even when we do we do it on scale I
mean it's like
you know it's like come on man oh so no
no not listen I'm old and I'm getting
tired
uh because when I first started there
was like a conspiracy theory that the
world was you've seen them all at this
point you know there's a guy here's one
this I was telling a friend of mine a
friend of mine was asking me about this
the other day and I said my answer to
him was
I read a book in 1982.
called bankruptcy 1984.
it was predicting the end of the U.S
economy in 1984 it was written by an
economist that was brilliant named Peter
Grace he was in charge of the grace
Commission in the Reagan Administration
and uh they were studying the increasing
national debt
and that the national debt was going to
cause the economy to collapse which I
think the national debt's stupid not a
control okay but this guy said it's
gonna hockey stick and the the monetary
policy is going to turn upside down
we've sucked all the cash out used it
for government stuff and the economy's
got no cash to operate on and so it's
going to collapse in 1984.
apparently wrong
and then another friend of mine wrote a
book called coming economic earthquake
didn't happen and then another guy wrote
a book talk about the collapse of the
economy and then another guy wrote a
book there's a lot oh and the Watson
okay I was going to collapse the economy
and then there was then when the planes
hit the towers the economy was not going
to recover because
um three thousand people died and Two
Towers fell in New York city so the
entire U.S economy was going to collapse
as a result of that and that went around
for a while and um and Silicon Valley
Bank the economy's got a tiny little
Bank over in San Francisco that no one
knew what it was except venture
capitalist has the power to bring down
the entire U.S economy it's just asinine
at some point it's like okay
I George if I ever write the book on the
end of the economy would you please
smack me I'll do that just make sure you
plan until after you're long after your
death so we can't blame you for it in
person and go no no boo boo no you're
wrong you would anyway you wouldn't you
go I know he's dead but he was stupid
yeah No One's Gonna say that about you
Dad yes they say it while I'm alive so
probably yeah this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay shop where we help
people build wealth do work that they
actually love and create real amazing
relationships George Campbell Ramsay
personality host of the popular YouTube
channel George camel camel with a K
check it out he is the king of snark you
will love it and he and Rachel Cruz do a
uh a wonderful afternoon show called
smart money happy hour ding yeah they
might have a drink on the show so you
need to check them out and they get
rather funny after they drink so check
them out Sharon Ramsey loves it and
that's the only review you need America
that's it that's all you need to know it
tells you everything you need and Sharon
listens to it and she doesn't listen to
this show so wow that that's there so
there's some hurt feelings to my left I
think there's bitterness here but it
could be now after 30 years she's not
impressed anymore 30 years of being on
the air and 40 years of marriage she's
not impressed at all takes a lot to
impress Sharon yeah we've managed to do
it yeah just yeah there you go so check
it out smart money happy hour hey this
is a baby steps millionaires theme hour
what is that that is where we talk to
real millionaires if you're a real
millionaire call in let me help you with
what a millionaire is because some
people don't know including a
congressman I heard speaking the other
day who's an idiot so a millionaire is
not someone that makes a million dollars
and a year Mr Congressman Mrs
Congressman you were wrong A Millionaire
is someone who has a million dollar net
worth that is different than your income
your net worth is what you own minus
what you owe assets minus liabilities
equals net worth when that is greater
than one million dollars and what you
own minus what you owe is greater than
one million dollars you are officially
by accounting definitions a millionaire
well I don't feel like it's not a
feeling no one should have that much
it's not a moral construct it's not
enough it's not a question of how much
you need for retirement it's a math
thing
when you have a million dollar net worth
you're a millionaire that's all it is
it's not you know we can answer and have
those other discussions if you want to
have them moral construct is it enough
and all that kind of stuff but it is a
million dollar net worth so if you
actually have a one million dollar or
greater net worth we want to talk to you
and find out how you got it because
there's a lot of Mythology floating
around about wealthy people in America
today uh let me say another way there's
a lot of stupid lies that are told about
uh wealthy people in America that just
by the uninformed ignorant and people
with an agenda trying to get you to vote
the wrong way and so there you go check
us out if you're a millionaire George
and I want to talk to you want to learn
how you did it the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Sarah is in Cincinnati Sarah what's
your net worth
good afternoon sir very much an honor to
speak with you long time listener my net
worth is 1.9 million very cool good for
you give me a little breakdown on that
what is that in what's the categories
that make up the 1.9
okay I have six buckets plus a retiree
medical account my house fully paid for
house 425
000 my bank uh checking and savings is
currently at at the 250 000 I've got
that amount in there
um I know I'm at the sdic limit I have a
Roth IRA at 232 371 taxable brokerage
268.26 an uh an opers 403 b retirement
at 501 and the Deferred Comp that's also
with my public employment at 190 862 and
then my retiree medical count is at 85
000. I just checked all my numbers
Sunday and that brings me to one million
nine hundred forty five thousand dollars
check it again it's probably over two
now way to go
way to go how old are you
I am 50
and how much is 1.9 million did you
inherit
I actually inherited
thirteen thousand dollars a gift from
him awesome that's very nice but to be
clear you were already a millionaire
yes sir so you did not become a
millionaire with inherited money
correct sir I just want to make sure
everybody hears that loud and clear
because that's one of the numbers we
hear about all the time way to go all
right so what do you do for a living
I am a registered nurse uh public in
public health I recently acquired my
master's degree in May of 21. okay what
was your GPA
uh probably about a 3.4 good for you
okay and your best your best working
year what did you make and your worst
working year since you've been working
what's your lowest income
yes uh last year because of mandated
overtime I was at a hundred and
seventeen thousand uh when I first
started working as a nurse in 1991 my
pay was 13.50 an hour prior to that I
worked as an aide a nurse aide at 550 an
hour wow so 13.50 an hour would be like
16 000 a year
correct and now I'm at 46 an hour
oh
and you so most of this time you've not
even made a hundred thousand
correct oh definitely definitely not but
in 2020 21 and 22 I just cleared a
hundred thousand because of mandated
overtime but prior to that I was around
90 000 a year but really over the last
20 years my average is probably about
sixty thousand dollars because when I
started in public health I was only
twenty two dollars an hour wow you were
like the poster child for our national
millionaire study
they didn't make six figures and
inheritance didn't cause them to become
a millionaire and you just consistently
invested over a long period of time
yes I started the Roth I wish I would
have started in my 20s but I heard the
Roth about 30 and then also put back in
the taxable brokerage and then when I
started with public employment they uh
match at 10 percent so they take 10 of
mine and match it at 10. so three 26
year old nurses are standing around the
coffee pot and you walk up and they're
saying no way a nurse can ever be a
millionaire what do you tell those three
oh I encourage this all the time in fact
I refer them to your information but I
talk to them all the time about putting
back at least in a Roth to start in a
Roth because I do know a lot of the
Health Care Systems don't have very good
programs necessarily public employment's
a little different but I encourage them
to start a Roth IRA and and Max it out
but basically you're telling them they
can do it
oh yes yes I've even discussed
um you know that I have built wealth
that way and they can do it too that my
house is paid for they usually encourage
to hear that Sarah you're amazing you're
amazing you're an absolute amazing lady
congratulations 54 years old 1.9 million
average income through a working life of
sixty thousand only in the last two
years did she even break six figures
and she's got a 1.9 million dollar net
worth oh to be fair 200 000 of the 1.9
was inherited after she was already a
millionaire 79 of America's millionaires
by the largest study of millionaire has
ever done and you can get that in the
millionaires the baby steps
Millionaire's book The study is in the
back of the book the entire white paper
on it you can unpack the details of for
you the Nerds if you're having trouble
sleeping
um put me right to sleep I know that
it's my study so uh 79 inherited
precisely zero five percent inherited a
small amount like five thousand dollars
not enough to make the millionaires
another five percent inherited money
after substantial money like her after
they were already millionaires five and
five and seventy nine would be called
89. that's nine out of ten of America's
millionaires are not millionaires
according to Stone Cold data because of
inheritance so when someone tells you
the only way you're going to be wealthy
is have a rich Uncle they're full of
crap
not true
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today this is
a baby steps millionaires theme hour if
you're a real millionaire with a net
worth of greater than a million dollars
what you own minus what you owe we want
to talk to you I don't want your broke
brother-in-law's opinion I want real
millionaires as to how they really did
it triple eight eight two five five two
two five let's do a little mental
exercise look ahead 90 days from now
it's July you have a thousand dollars in
the bank
you paid off two of your credit cards
and you check out at the grocery without
having a panic attack you know how that
would feel
peaceful financially peaceful Financial
Peace
some of you have never had that in your
entire life but today is the day that
you can look take it Take Back Control
of your money it starts in Financial
Peace University it's our nine-week
course that's helped millions of people
beat debt build wealth and become
outrageously generous we're going to
teach you everything about how to handle
money step by step so you don't have to
worry about it anymore the average
student going through Financial Peace
University has an eight thousand dollar
turnaround in 90 days fifty three
hundred dollars in debt reduction 2700
in savings that's the average total of
eight thousand not a bad return on your
time
if I could give you eight thousand
dollars in three months would you take a
talk about it we should talk about it
that means before summer break is over
you're going to feel different go to
Financial Peace University today at
ramseysolutions.com FPU and get signed
up you'll be amazed at how inexpensive
it is get plugged into a group where
people love you encourage you and hold
you accountable
and that'll ensure that this works
Financial Peace University
ramseysolutions.com FPU David is in
Milwaukee hi David what is your net
worth
hey Dave George thanks for taking my
call uh my net worth as of last night is
1 million sixty five thousand dollars
look at you I like it very good and uh
give me a little breakdown by category
how's that made up
uh so cash is around ninety thousand uh
retirement counts with 401k and and Roth
IRAs around 190 uh brokerage accounts uh
with 50 000 and real estate's the big
one here at 735 000. very cool good for
you how old are you
I'm 32 my wife is 30. and how much of
this 1.1 million did you inherit
zero all right zero precisely okay so
you've been working 10 years or so what
was your best working year household
income and worst year
uh when my wife and I were both working
together we were probably probably in
the 220 range I would say
um that are best year uh since then
she's she's become a stay-at-home now
she's been working at home and we're
probably around the 200 Mark now I was
that's your worst year ever is 200.
uh
uh meat no sorry sorry uh one about 120
120 On The Low End okay cool what do you
all do for a living what do you do
I'm an electrical engineer okay very
good all right and what was your GPA
a bachelor's was
3.8 3.9 Masters like
3.5-ish I want to say okay good for you
well done well done so uh you think this
can be done today if you got somebody
out there listening that's an engineer
just coming out of school at 22 23 years
old can they still become a millionaire
in 10 years
oh 100 100 I think as long as you have
as long as you have a vision of what
you're trying to accomplish and you can
you can lay a goal in front of yourself
and uh you know put together some simple
steps and then just have discipline and
on you know repeating those steps month
after month year after year I think it's
an inevitable fact honestly so I'm
curious David because you're you're so
young and people like to you know poo
poo on folks that are young who have
built wealth because they just don't
think it's possible for them so what
would you tell that person did it was it
the paid for house well how intentional
were you over these 10 years to do this
or did you just look up one day and go
oh my gosh here we are
no we were extremely intentional and
this started off in 2015 when I when I
got out of got out of school I mean in
2015 and I had a net worth of of
negative 50 000 and um the the first
thing was jumping into in the FPU
um jumped into FPU paid off those
student loans in the first in the first
12 months of of my career and um we
started saving for our first house and
paid cash for our first house right out
of the gate it was a a duplex
um two years later we paid cash for
another rental property and uh now we've
moved into a third place as well so
we've been really just just slow and
steady like Dave always says you know
the slow and steady wins the race wow
that will get rich slow plan works and
here you are at 32. it didn't take you
30 years
well sometimes I hear all rich people
are Crooks how much of this did you
steal
as far as I know a zero
unless my CPA messed up or something but
uh
well I just had to ask I want to make
sure we get all the all the facts out
here hey man I'm proud of you way to go
congratulations very very well done
Jason in Lexington what is your net
worth
hey Dave it is 1.3 million good for you
give me a little breakdown by category
yeah it's about a third of it is in our
personal property a third of it is in
retirement accounts 401ks IRAs and a
third of it is in investment property
okay so real estate all right and so
good very good how old are you
I'm 49 years old and my wife is 47.
excellent excellent how much of this did
you inherit
not a darn Penny unfortunately
what do you do for a living
I am in technology sales so I actually
worked for one of those big large tech
companies that had all the layoffs and
coincidentally enough
um my commission check hit I'm in sales
while I was laid off so technically we
became millionaires while I was
unemployed
that's impressive
I'll take it I'll take it every time
what's your degree in
is in computer science I was a developer
for many years started listening to you
back in 2007 started looking for an
opportunity to you know get a bigger
shovel so I moved over into sales Ah
that's interesting and what was your GPA
in computer science
o is about a 3.2 okay and what was your
all's best working year since you've
been working household income and worst
working year the range so this year will
be our best year it'll be somewhere
around 700 000 it's a bit of an outlier
you know how sales go worst year I'd
have to go all the way back to when I
was in the Army to have my absolute
worst year but let's see let's go in the
last 10 years about 180 000. okay all
right so
seven hundred thousand and you got laid
off
exactly the best year I've ever had it's
like laid me off every year wow
that's so interesting I wonder what the
correlation to that is we don't want to
pay this guy 700 000. we're going to lay
him off hmm okay but but they had to pay
they had to pay the commission that was
on the books right they did pay what was
on the book so I guess if there's an
ethical way to fire people they did it
wow call it a severance and next year
they just won't have all those sales
exactly but I've already landed in a new
place it's a better place you know and
the nice thing is when I got the email
and yes I was fired over an email
um I just looked at my wife that morning
I was like well I guess I'm taking some
vacation
that's what you can do when you got
Financial Peace amen when you're 49
years old and you're worth 1.3 million
and you don't mean debt way to go man
way to go so uh tell the young techies
out there can this still be done or is
all the opportunity in America gone
it can be done in you know doing it the
right way doing it slow growth is always
less painful is always better you know
in the last 16 years we've had lots of
different economies we've had certainly
different types of presidents and it's
never affected me one bit keeping my
head down concentrating on what my wife
and I can control within our sphere of
influence and uh what we can affect has
always been the right approach in the
last uh 25 years which will put you down
to 25 years old what's the dumbest thing
you did with money
you know when we were really young when
I was stationed in Germany we bought a
brand new car
1994 Dodge Avenger we put 300 down on it
went home and freaked out went back the
next day and canceled it we did not get
our 300 back so out of all the things
you can do stupid with money 300 will
take it with a well lesson learned yeah
wow didn't have to and just took the
call that that's amazing yeah sweet car
I'm glad you didn't get it
very cool very cool are you a reader or
a TV person
oh I read I would try to read two books
a month ah okay High correlation between
people who build wealth
they read books instead of watching
you're saying love is blind season four
will not help me build wealth and I'm
pretty sure neither will Tiger King dang
it but computer strategy could be wrong
I'm just helping you people out here
with your inputs inputs matter Wow way
to go man good job Jason this is a baby
steps millionaire theme hour
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today this is
a baby steps billionaires theme hour
where we're talking to real millionaires
about how they really got there not your
broke brother-in-law's opinion not
somebody trolling on the internet these
are actual humans that have actually
done it which is really probably a
pretty good source of information James
is with us in Miami hi James how much is
your net worth
I'm sitting just shy of 1.1 I'm at 1
million seventy five thousand perfect
give me a little breakdown by category
all right well about 450 000 is home
equity uh 255 000 is in my tsp I've got
250 000 throughout Roth IRA mutual funds
a couple single stocks in HSA about 80
000 in cash and forty thousand in paid
off Vehicles good for you cool how old
are you
I am 28 28 year old millionaire look at
you man way to go how much of this did
you inherit
zero zero and what's your best working
year and your worst working year
income-wise
uh the worst working year was back in
2015 when I started entering the
workforce I made about 50 000 that year
okay and my best working year was last
year made about 250 000. cool what do
you do for a living
I'm an air traffic controller ah okay so
what is that a lot of overtime or what
yeah it was mostly over time the whole
pandemic we just started going crazy
with the overtime I jumped up my salary
by about 30 000 one year in 2021 by just
taking a bunch of OT and then in 2022
same thing just a lot of overtime very
cool very cool what's your degree in
I actually don't have a degree
okay cool uh votech or anything I went
to college for about two and a half
years uh about it was a four-year
program and about a year and a half into
it the government changed their minds
which they always do about how to hire
people so you don't need a degree for
that field anymore wow okay and your GPA
in high school then was what
same in college for those two and a half
years good for you so what do you
attribute to the fact that you're a
millionaire at a 28 at 28 years old what
how did that happen What do you call
that
I think a lot of it is I want to throw
it back to my parents how I was raised
through that and how they instilled that
work ethic in me they both put in you
know 60 plus hours a week and my mom was
a small business owner and just seeing
her hustle and grind was really a big
driving force towards it but that didn't
give you any money they just gave you an
example
correct and also I work out to work in
the business growing up so I got to
start earning my own money from a young
age
okay so what were the specific steps you
took over the last seven eight years
where you doing 15 retirement did you
wait and get a bigger down payment what
were the Tactical pieces of this
oh I kind of messed up uh probably about
two years into the job I got a big pay
raise when I started getting checked out
and certified on positions I took out
pay raise and I got a brand new car ah
so that was one mistake there but after
that I learned and I started investing
all the other repair reasons after that
so you just lived on less than you made
after that and went I'm gonna sock this
money away in retirement and pay down
the house and I'll get to millionaire
status was it intentional to get there
yes it was very intentional I always had
the goal I wanted to be a millionaire by
age 30. and you did it and suddenly a
couple of couple years ago I saw the end
in sight and was able to see a million
dollar
coming up on it yeah Wow way to go rob
excellent excellent work uh I'm sorry
James excellent work very well done good
good good job Rob is in Atlanta Rob
what's your net worth
hi my network is right about 4.2 4.3
million very cool give me a little
breakdown by category
yeah I've got two million and uh 401K uh
1.3 about in uh just uh mutual funds and
things like that about eight hundred
thousand dollars in the house and the
rest and just cash and a few other
things good good very cool how old are
you
I just turned 58. good for you and uh
how much of this uh 4.2 million did you
inherit
uh basically zero we just got uh my
mother-in-law passed away this uh last
year so we got 90 000 just in the last
year but you were already
multi-millionaires
exactly yeah
so what's your best working your income
and your worst working your income
uh probably my worst was in graduate
school probably eight thousand dollars a
year and my best will probably be this
year
um I think my wife and I will probably
make about 300 000 together good for you
what do you all do for a living
I work in research and development in a
big consumer Products Company okay cool
what's your degree in
I have a master's in chemical
engineering okay
something you're using in r d every day
yeah good for you okay kind of yeah I'm
in management now so yeah but I mean you
know though you know the formulas what's
the uh what was your GPA
uh 3.2 undergrad and 3.9 graduate yeah
way to go cool
so I think this is an underhand pitch
since you're a master's degree to
chemical engineer but are you a book
reader or TV watcher
I'm a uh I'd say I'm an information
gatherer I don't read a ton of books to
be honest but I gather information from
all over the place I I read yeah your
Airfield is somewhat like the medical
field so you're reading articles all the
time
all the time and just personal stuff you
know car repair I enjoy doing that kind
of stuff
anything where I can use my hands and
learn how to do something I enjoy yeah
but didn't see every uh particular
episode of Downton Abbey and no no
well now he's got time to watch it
now you can catch up uh that's what we
aspire to right I love it brother well
done aggressive so your advice to the uh
28 year old version of you
yeah well I I think like everybody else
it's you know spend spend less than you
make um it makes things a lot more
comfortable another one that I haven't
heard too much is I I really don't like
to pay somebody else to do something I
can do so I'm willing to work pretty
hard to you know do things that
um other people might just pay somebody
to do and I really don't do much of that
you know something I get uh people
sometimes criticize me I'm not asking
and I think it's a valid criticism uh do
you or your wife smoke
no no no you know when you start asking
that because I think there's a high
probability they don't because it it a
it's obviously a medical issue B costs a
lot and uh I'll bet you we find a
correlation I've never asked it before
yeah it's an expensive habit you know
because it just costs a lot and yeah you
go through a couple packs a day it's a
big deal and uh yeah so interesting very
interesting hey man very cool I'm proud
of you thanks for the call we appreciate
you calling in it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour now the
mythology if you listen to the internet
trolls the Reddit fools the Tic Tac
people whatever they are uh or your
broke brother-in-law who votes the wrong
way they're going to tell you that
wealthy people all inherited their
wealth we've already told you 89 did not
become millionaires Stone Cold research
because of inherited wealth we can prove
it to you you disagree with that you're
what's known as wrong this is data okay
the law of gravity is data it works
every time it's called facts the uh the
vast majority of wealthy people are
Crooks George have you heard that I've
heard that one we got to be evil to make
money Dave
which is very interesting because if you
own a
uh restaurant and you rip people off
people don't come back and they tell
people to stay away if you own a car
repair place and you rip people off they
don't come back and they tell people to
stay away I'm confused how the crooks
Prosper over the Long Haul now they
might Prosper that week but it's very
difficult to become wealthy it's easier
to become wealthy with actual high
integrity because they as your customers
will come back you know whether you're
yeah sure because you can't keep your
job if you lie and steal and it's all
that and oh they're all famous
entertainers they're NFL athletes
they're uh you know they're country
music stars they're rock stars I didn't
get a single call from them today yeah
they're just Engineers haven't talked to
one of those sales people yeah the
nurses the truth is the data tells us
that it's less than two percent of
millionaires are celebrity types
almost none of them are celebrity types
and uh celebrity types have a horrible
reputation of handling money well by the
way as a general rule some some do a
good job but but the reputation is bad
to say the least this is a baby steps
Millionaire's theme hour
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
4 25 and 26 let your eyes look straight
ahead fix your gaze directly before you
give careful thought to the paths for
your feet and be steadfast in all your
ways George Lucas says you simply have
to put one foot in front of the other
and keep going
put blinders on and plow right ahead
this is a baby steps millionaires theme
hour we're talking to real millionaires
if you want to know more on this subject
the book number one bestseller these my
eighth number one bestseller is called
Baby Steps Millionaires and it came out
about 14 months ago and it's stories of
real millionaires that really did this
stuff and it saw data from the actual
millionaire study the study is published
as an appendix in the back and we go
through
exactly how people walk this process out
and exactly how over 30 years I've
observed them doing it and we defeat all
of the lies that the Hope Stealers put
out
and the Hope Stealers are out there they
were trained by Karl Marx
in the college classroom
and it's just not true that you're stuck
or that America is so broken that you
can't win yes there's lots of problems
yes there's lots of obstacles if being
successful was easy no one would care
about being successful
everyone would get a participation
Trophy and we'd call it a day and we'd
call it communism but there's a real way
that real people get up leave the cave
kill something and drag it home and they
become real Millionaires and no they did
not inherit their money and no they're
not Crooks and no they're not rich
people and oh by the way if you're so
stupid
that you think a house George was
telling me this at the break that a paid
for house does not count in your net
worth then you don't understand
basic accounting
okay and they don't teach that on Tick
Tock all right basic accounting if you
take Accounting 101 they're going to
teach you what a net worth is a balance
sheet
and a balance sheet net worth is your
assets minus your liabilities it's very
simple and very clean and your assets
are anything cars count
you have a hundred thousand dollars in
cars that counts towards your net worth
and I hope to God it's not much of your
net worth but it counts as part of your
net worth you know if you own whatever
it just you know there's a if you want
to say someone's a cash millionaire or a
liquid millionaire that's a different
definition that would be a million
dollars cash or liquid assets uh mutual
funds that you could get out uh not in a
retirement account but your retirement
accounts your hard assets even valuable
personal items okay if you had a bunch
of collectible art that counts in your
net worth I don't recommend it but in
terms of a high percentage of your net
worth but it counts and if you don't
think so you're what's known as wrong
so really you have to start dealing with
facts here and well it doesn't count why
do you want why do you want it to be
impossible
well you whiners want it to be
impossible someone hurt them and they
just can't get over it maybe it was a
breakup maybe it was some childhood
trauma I don't know but they're in the
YouTube comments Dave and I gotta deal
with them
someone's got to settle down because you
actually look at the YouTube comments
that's the difference well I just I
can't help see idiots just get to be
free you have to deal with them the
problem is I think it was a Mark Twain
quote if you start a fight with an idiot
no they'll drag you down and onlookers
can't tell the difference argue with a
pig yeah don't don't get in the mud with
a pig because nobody can tell which is
which you know that's the thing yeah
sure hey wow you know but we just our
goal here we want to prove to you that
you can win it's that simple and it's
not it's not Pollyanna Pollyanna it's
not it's not fake
um and it you know if it goes against
their your little victim mentality well
good that's what we're trying to do is
break your little victim mentality Amy's
in Dallas what's your net worth Amy
two point
million dollars way to go give me a
little breakdown on that
you're breaking up honestly breaking up
we need a new phone oh okay
there we go
one million in retirement which is 401K
in Roth IRAs 400 400k I'm guessing on
the house 700k in in brokerage accounts
and Company stock and then 100K in cash
and I do apologize Dave I did not
incorporate things with wheels and
Motors that's okay because they go down
in value that's okay um
I'm not yelling at you for that I'm
yelling at people who say that George's
house has a million dollar net worth
doesn't count because he got about a 700
000 paid for a house and he's 32 years
old so of course it counts right yeah
that's just dumb so anyway all right so
how old are you I'm 34 and my husband
will be 33 this year excellent excellent
how much of this did you inherit
um I think about 50k my husband did when
his grandfather passed away but that was
well after we were already millionaires
okay we rest our case all right cool and
what do you guys do for a living
um we met in college and we were both
studying electrical engineering he won
the lottery I was the only female in
class
yeah we double dipped on the electrical
engineering what was your uh GPA
uh mine was 3.3 his was 3.1 very cool
what do you tell people if they want to
be a millionaire by 34 years old
um honestly God's money that you are
entrusted to manage and the biggest
thing in your Bible verse today was
perfect
be okay with the laid gratification
understand the past and it's okay that
you're not going to have the flashy cars
right now because you're gonna have it
later
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else
yes sir yeah in the Bible verse another
one is no discipline seems Pleasant at
the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness Amy you're amazing
congratulations so George we had a 1.9 a
1.1 a 1.3 a 1.1 a 4.2 and a 2.2 million
dollar net worth today 54 years old 32
49 28 54 or 58 and 34 years old it's all
none over 60 and one under 30 and two in
their 30s is a young crowd today average
GPA 3.4 3.8 3.2 3.5 3.2 3.3 so they
always think the other one of the other
mythologies is you have to be unusually
brilliant to be wealthy and uh you can't
be unusually dumb
that the 1.6 doesn't show up okay if you
play beer pong in college you're
probably not going to show up here uh if
that was your graduate degree is in beer
pong um but the most of the time the
average Millionaire's net worth is a
little over three
mine was a little under three to 2.97 to
be precise and I'm very bitter about
that three one hundred so just bump it
round it up three one hundredths of a
point and I missed it yeah there you go
but uh so I graduated thank you Lodi you
know that's what that means so there you
go but anyway but yeah that's the
average millionaires right around that
three Mark uh very few of them are
certified Geniuses but very few of them
are dumb they they have a lot of them
are Engineers number one
um number one category of careers by the
way is Engineers number two is
accountant number three is teacher
number four is business number five is
attorney number six is medical so
medical didn't even make doctors didn't
even make the top five wow so and we had
them all here today we had Engineers
Tech sales air traffic controller r d
nurse see there you see anything yeah
it's represented engine lots of
Engineers chemical engineer electrical
engineer electrical engineer uh the the
first call 54 year old nurse a single
had been in public nursing her whole
life never made over a hundred thousand
until last year year before last year so
uh one third of millionaires never make
over a hundred thousand in their life
one third of them in a study so why do
we do all this because we want to tell
you you can do it
it's possible
and the mix is interesting too there's
nothing real sexy in this mix it's just
I paid down my house got it paid for I
put money in my 401k I've got a
brokerage account with some mutual funds
in it and I've got cash there was not an
Elon Musk or Bill Gates on the list I
was waiting for something crazy but
there wasn't much in there kind of
boring but it just works what's not
boring is having Financial Peace and
retiring when you want to amen amen
there we go so hey this is how this
stuff works boys and girls it's slow and
steady wins the race and we invite you
to join the race congratulations America
check out baby steps millionaires check
out Financial Peace University we'll get
you going it's what we do here
good show George well done well done
well done puts this hour in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to ramsesolutions.com
today to sign up for the newsletter
again that's ramseysolutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]